[Music]
summer next time we're hiding in a
calorical echo nest can you do me a
favor and turn your ringer off despite
what the subtitles say it's still not
entirely clear what's being dealt with
here was it a clerkian echo that had a
nest or was it a calorican that had an
echo nest how am i supposed to update
the fan wiki now dan that's because
losers look stuff up turn right pink
shirt girl in this episode of this
television show darn right to live is to
risk it all otherwise you're just an
inert chunk of randomly assembled
molecules drifting wherever the universe
blows you show makes us question whether
or not this statement was actually
profound or just a setup to burn jerry
cool just stay in the driveway the
killbots are live and i took you off the
white list good thing you just randomly
stopped right before walking into the
garage then or bad thing yeah let's go
with bad thing back in the very first
episode of rick and morty tv since we
made a joke about this towing company
and finished by sending that toes don't
bend like that we were then inundated in
the comments with people saying that
their toes do in fact bend like that and
i say [ __ ] i'm giving 10 sins to you
toe scam liars seriously if you can
extend your big toe and still fully flex
all four of your other toes to where the
pads of the toe are touching the bottom
of your foot i'll give 20 sins back in
the next rick and morty episode we said
and name drop you for it just send the
proof to pixar it didn't happen at
cinemasins.com for verification and
absolutely not because i want to look at
pictures of strangers feet as far as you
know half open boxes in the mattress
leaning up against the side secured only
by this tall and unstable lamp the sin
is jerry loading his truck like a jerry
insults can someone help me understand
if butts or faces and faces or butts in
this world then what part of the butt is
butt face morty watching the face butt
porn with and what orifice on the face
butt do butt faces use to you know what
i just decided i don't want to know any
of this dang it quickly please this
episode is not titled mad rick morty
road the exploding war boy on the back
of their vehicle has little to no impact
on them or the car proving that even a
show with an established plot device for
replacing main characters can also be
shameless in its use of plot
armor [ __ ] love post-apocalyptic
versions of art people that believe in
climate change but still don't give a
[ __ ] this stuff's so powerful morty it
makes isotope 465 look like isotope 317.
this techno babble is so star trek tng
it makes doctor who look like
sliders your blood will be my lotion
blood would be a terrible ocean dries up
almost immediately and then you walk
around smelling like iron and looking
like a giant scab this creature with a
horizontal hydraulic denture mouth
harmonica nose face speaks lies is it
really easier to eat human flesh and to
just tell me why we're still here
no
[Laughter]
no matter how many times you watch these
episodes there's always that one joke
that hits hard and this is the one that
did it for me uh you mean the blood dome
save it for the semantics dome eb white
i'm this close to giving another cent
off for yet another hilarious bit but
then i realized that calling the blood
dome the thunderdome isn't just a
semantic difference blood is very
different than thunder although i do
hide under the covers the moment i
experience either of them this device
extracts and redistributes muscle memory
this macguffin has fired so ungracefully
up the ass of this episode i have to
give it two sins even though its
penetration in the end will be quite
enjoyable letting this bicep meat rot in
the heat and some chose to huddle near
the boomy holes calling it your boomy
hole and letting someone huddle near it
for the vert vertis on billy boards did
the boomy booms blow up all your wordy
word books summer would be furiosa tv
since nipple suspenders as a fashion
statement super cool nipple suspenders
as your chosen blood dome uniform
[ __ ] liability man good thing the
lady in the water arm chose this moment
to stop destroying everything in its
vicinity the second summer showed up huh
this neck keeps pulsing more blood out
of it and honestly sometimes i think the
show forgets that disgusting things can
be distracting things and if they're not
careful i might not be paying close
enough attention to catch the next fart
joke
we'll be right back aside from the usual
nonsense fourth wall breaking this
should also be said for how it allows
the show to fast forward through how
rick got out of this situation why
summer sided with the death stalkers and
if morty's monster arm got in some quick
dealt work before it suddenly decided to
drive him out here chopping wood
one-handed wait chopping wood
left-handed
now i'm gonna
narrating your whipping is only
acceptable if a problem comes along and
you whip it good what about the weird
guys on leashes then they're more like
interns this [ __ ] claims to have
little memory of the before four times
so this means that internships as a
concept have survived the apocalypse
actually it makes perfect sense that
something is soulless and evil would
survive the end of the world but still
[ __ ] internships can i
see
no one has seen my true face and lived
scene does not contain a baby yoda a
metal bucket is on a certain level a
kind of mustache in that it's a specific
facial accessory a mustache is not just
a facial accessory it's a growing and
ever-changing part of you that requires
care and nurturing so it can one day
become a full and prominent statement of
your desire to never drink milk in
public ever again the thing i find most
disconcerting about this whole scene is
how all of them just sit there
conversing with an entire meatball on
their fork i have so many questions like
aren't you worried about the sauce
dripping all over the place as you
gesture are you planning on eating the
entire meatball in one bite are you not
including any spaghetti with the
meatball they are meant to be eaten
together you savages and that's before
we even get to your serving sizes that
plate of spaghetti is as big as your
head that's probably 3 000 calories
worth of spaghetti there and i'm not
even counting the pureed egg yolk drink
you've included dial it back summer by
15 and increase dynamic movement by
three no matter how many times this show
tries to explain away beth being
oblivious to all things rick because of
the issues with their relationship she
has also been established to be a very
smart person only takes a moderately
smart person like myself to see through
this robotic family ruse plus dynamic
movement adjustments are always done in
increments of five otherwise what's the
point you millennials
generationalizations
please slavery was a family business
that's his business the flashback we saw
earlier was of his men murdering the
entire village the writers think someone
could be this bad at business and also
have a taint washer uh armothy can i
steal you for a second armathy armathy
what about arm and fight or steve jobs i
mean hand squish him anderson was right
there maybe the lesson we've learned is
that i don't get to do this with rick
and morty so skip
i did all this in three weeks i mean my
neighbor started putting up a fence in
his backyard three months ago and he's
still not done part of the sit is
probably on my lazy neighbor [ __ ]
bruce but this is still a lot of
infrastructure for 21 days we were
monsters we didn't care about anything i
still don't yeah except i'm the only one
in this entire world that's still
committed to that oh
ding ding ding ding ding ding three sins
oh i get it you want me to send the
marriage kills romance and results in
conflict cliche fair enough here's your
ding ding ding no union built on running
from your problems last more than five
years seven tops usa deniers
[Music]
no unless my suffering is your
nourishment tv sins
that's says spicy meat the ball
it's because losers look stuff up while
the rest of us are carbon all them dms
belief like fear or love
is a force to be understood as we
understand the theory of relativity and
principles of uncertainty
kill me please i won't kill you but i
don't have to save you how come you guys
dress like you're in a theme park stunt
show but these guys wear khakis and
hockey jerseys this is the way after the
boom boom some adapted to the new truth
you speak the true truth and
and
he
wants
giving them exactly what they want
i'll be right back deathstalkers bring
me his flesh leather
sorry my grandpa stole your god and
ruined your car you don't turn your back
on family
even when they do
i am summer summer state your deal you
already know my name and you can see
that i'm a machine i don't know why i'm
crying why are you crying there's no
crying